so there was a an article just came in
the allied times from brian cranston
ryan cranston was was just being
interviewed and cranston
has now
turned down
a part in a play because he felt the
part was was
too much partaking of his white
privilege he said i'm 65 years old
and i need to learn
i need to change
brian cranston needs to overcome
his white
privilege and this is really pathetic
what he does brent cranston has a lot of
privilege because he's one of the most
famous wealthy well-known performers in
the entire world
but this this kind of stuff is is really
pathetic i don't think it persuades
anyone i don't think it persuades black
people i don't think it persuades white
people i don't think it persuades any of
the other races of people i think it
persuades a very small percentage of
radicals
and and brian cranston actually went on
to make this interesting point
the new play
that he's doing is about the limits of
free speech he's saying look there's no
such thing as free speech absolutism
there's no such thing as having no
limits or taboos in in speech and in
standards and in society that's actually
the same point as my book he's brian
cranston is basically doing a play right
now about my book but the standards that
he wants are completely insane they're
leftist leftist standards
okay the
yes it's true the truckers and the blm
people who shut down the highways
they're doing kind of the same act
but the substance of that act is very
different
my friend andrew clavin points this out
consensual sex between a loving husband
and a wife and rape
can look
kind of like the same physical act but
they're completely different acts
because the substance is different
because the spiritual component is
different because the t loss of it is
different okay and that's what that's
what we're going to need to dig into we
need to dig into to what those
boundaries should be and what we want
our society for and if you're the one
killing the puppies you're probably the
bad guy you all know about the ring
video doorbell you know because i've
been telling you about it for years that
amazing doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door whether
you're in the house on the road in the
office wherever you are in the world
well did you know that ring makes an
alarm
yes ring makes a powerful alarm system
and that professional monitoring will
give you the ultimate peace of mind it's
part of a ring protect subscription and
there are no long-term commitments it's
incredible you can install it yourself
it takes two seconds to install it
seriously i mean even even i am not the
most handy guy in the world you can
really do it quite quickly it's much
less expensive than the traditional
home protection sort of services it'll
protect your home not only from the bad
guys but from freeze fire flood it's
great go check out that award-winning
ring alarm system go to ring.com knowles
k-w-l-e-s to get a great deal on a ring
alarm security kit today that is
ring.com
knowles you and your family can thank me
later did you like that clip i hope you
liked that clip if you did leave me a
comment just say hey michael i you know
i enjoyed that that was nice thank you i
like your hair today that's a lovely
sweater you got to subscribe you got to
ring that bell get all the notifications
for the next videos and maybe let's say
you're not getting the notifications for
whatever reason youtube head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]